anyway so welcome back I'm joined on the
long way in super podcast
Cindy Webster suck George Lee on the
John from the lean machines
say hello everyone I don't know he's
doing now we asked online for some
suggestions for people to ask you
questions and answers big event tomorrow
first question how you guys feeling for
the comic tomorrow you've seen the
workouts now you know what's coming up
are we feeling this doing fun to compete
with the boys system VLR very different
workouts but we used to yeah I'm feeling
no [ __ ] stress for kids obviously on
the biggest athlete out before I love
weight I'm nobody normally when I'm on
my own it's it's hard but with these
free to carry a choice I don't know how
I'm gonna get through
so we asked on instagram for some
questions from people and we got a mixed
bag some sensible some sensible ones
some less sensible ones and someone
asked what are the best supplementing
exercises to an overhead squat let's
start with the serious one man yeah okay
so the mainframe exercise is overhead
squat would be behind the depressed in
naturally violet present snatch grip
obviously to me whenever you're trying
to improve overhead squat I always
suggest people there's no shortcuts
around you've got practice the actual
movement so for me actually just work in
a range where you can keep a good
position it's what
one thing you have in terms of other
supplement exercises that I like to do
would be something like slots press
because I brung me that really helps our
lives in that exercise working on my
program ability I thought really helps
me eat my chest up more and new pence
walks that's another very good exercise
and finally if anyone is strong as well
with their ankle mobility yes on the
work and actually loosen up the charts
it works in your range of motion there
also make the overheads definitely a
definitive answer if I would I use the
box back in today going to use the box I
did really have the head for it as in
like mentally so I would probably go
back to boxing between that because they
get sponsors off like party a city has
spent most of the weekend bouncing
between different top level designers is
going to the saachi's house later on
before never to Richard Branson's I hear
he's on Richard Russell Island you came
in by winkles why does SUNY with
impeccable timing and coordination and
lifting sub so Pilate doubloons
[Laughter]
he's that tradesman I once had this
heavy bro like and he snapped it and
ever since that monster haven't got a
new rope I want a new heavy rope and
I'll get them back
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm not m Jordan 93 I don't know if this
is a question or not
moaning girlfriends that don't
understand why you do what you do in the
Sun if that's a question what we more
talking about that how you still with
relationships probably that's from you
boy like maybe in the sea rose my
partner couldn't be any less bobble by
exercise like she doesn't do it doesn't
do it and she gives me 0 [ __ ] for doing
it I just like your thing you do it and
I don't push her into it so I think I
think if that comes down to who your
partner is yeah yeah it sure pays son my
relationship slightly different
obviously with my wife she's in the
social media wealth and fitness world as
well so it's it's a little bit easier
for her to understand but also you know
what I think we gotta secure your trade
and what you do
somebody should always just to support
it
you know if you guys don't say if you've
got a partner who gives you crap for
going to the gym normally because
they're I mean they're quite you sure
about themselves they give you crap
about your job unless you know now
generalize it unless you back though
taught this way is still a it must be
hard though being like obviously a long
relationship I think that it must be
always part of your where realized that
they will be waste car second that's
especially well that must be deal with
it must be not be interesting for you
because you're in a relationship with
two like he's in my top level athletes
in it right like is yourself and your
misters yeah yeah so she understand that
what it takes to have it be a [ __ ]
sport so for me it's again it's pretty
great constant situation so you just
find that she's giving out on like wow
like you Jess you the next day I said if
you do sprints tomorrow for work you
don't you'll pull your hamstring yeah I
mean I went there first time so I'm
super competitive she was killing me but
none of these old boys put about 60
years old and like they will keep it
look at me as I fit announce it on yeah
and then first print try to be the full
mansion so that's not making it's like
seven more rounds in the corner yeah she
trained just as I do so that's great
understand Thanks how do you personally
attack a new PR you PR today yeah I do
PR today I don't have a not go warm up
there about 90 seconds and then yeah
well today yeah Adam is 10 minutes I
miss I miss what sunny yeah I'll let you
tell talk about your optimal warm-up
strategy with yes I normally warm up
about 40 minutes do something about
class at all
I've seen you cold bar 160 I think he
getting BB is a lot it's down to
atmosphere as well like yeah I don't
make you be when I'm with these boys
like obviously mine are a lot lighter
than Zak in Sonny's but I think you hit
it when you miss it before you even
lifted it it's completely in your head
right whether you if you've got a doubt
then given the point with my lens at the
time when I bought the hour when I said
like a heavy lift
it's either when I'm with Zach or sunny
and it's not anything that they're
saying or doing it's purely just well is
what they're doing they lifted weights
so heavy that when I'm going up to my
measly 90 kilos for a snatch I see them
warm album barely bend their knees to
get it so exciting just approaching you
oh and we don't get out accurately so it
doesn't feel it strangely doesn't feel
heavy anymore
[Music]
a team behind you always even go in the
gym today really long so you do when you
get to well when you did on the
Augustine standard body power yeah 140
called 160 170 170 was what you need it
again so it's three like to warm up sets
and I think he's quite impressive like
having spent having chained to you a lot
about your training as of recently about
the fact that you you seem to never
really get knocked off a lot guys that
are know in the gym who
little bit tied a little bit flew a
little bit hungover but you're like
through a nuclear war had half an hour's
sleep hot shot at Regionals and sunny
one of the heaviest nights of my life I
was so ill the next day and I don't
really get hangovers I don't know he was
still drunk
he had a Red Bull and went the snacks
one for each their way yo John John
doesn't like really worried about
hangovers he we were actually in the cab
and he pilot starts talking to the
camera goes down you're gonna have to do
it today I plan he was in early but he
was in a bad place - new day of his
hands on his knees
right so cam powerlifting helped
weightlifting don't really like Paula
with it especially not a lot bench
pressing yeah I think is if you have a
good little strength I would say to one
finger I think would actually it would
benefit it's not you know one thing
would do is you would stop worrying
about heavy weights moving big heavy
weights it's never going to become an
issue in this like when you go and
upload to eight yeah yeah you're not
really gonna worry about doing the clink
but you'd be surprised how many people
from their lip do it today that we get
nowhere near 100 oh yeah that's gonna be
age dependent typically the longer
opinion is for Howard if your wife is
use the tighter you're going to get and
if you're 18 you've been empowered over
two years you're probably gonna have a
PC crossover into CrossFit or
weightlifting if you're 40 min power to
think the last 30 years the chance of
you get to the bottom of snatch with
speed it's gonna be it also depends as
well at what type of power can you're
doing it could do it a quick power lip
thing or a frog yeah if you using the
power lifting movements together and
using them as a full range do we get
better wait exactly but you gotta wake
up than half the time doing I've spent
my life going my mustache doesn't
connect in the middle what systems
exercises help you the most to avoid
this is it true that your shave like one
of the guys I think one of the girls at
high score and she spent I just was just
hanging out one day and I remember her
saying that she hated it because her dad
had a hug me feet because they yeah
hairy toes so I went home and shake my
show they're not my big toes like super
area shaving body parts it would
probably mean that time to explain what
happened that funny when the funny
singer mister my
so we first photoshoot Leon I ever did
it was
and obviously it's a big boat Ferry Road
waiver was we're leaning away like we're
doing it you know really cool tug O'War
a star cos we're leaning away and he
just suddenly I deceived with to stare
at each other like this is so weird
and I just suddenly see his eyes go tell
the kids kept going in on the edges
yes crap back now it's ugly around the
outside this is really short Bibble in a
minute this is just like a cold snap
yeah is it too late to start
weightlifting at 18 years old do you
think this is a byproduct to the fact
that a lot of people that are good and
they do it do it young like you talked
about the fact you don't since you're 11
12 years old except of course they do it
for three years that is so naturally
they're never made more important again
into weightlifting later it depends like
if you want to be a compact
that will wake that they're starting a
Haiti that is quite there but then to
say that like my old trading partner
Brad he's died at 18 he went to become a
bit so I don't believe that's to lay it
just need to be sensible and how much
probably a background than that this
coil is going to carry over the
transition could be quite quick I
started saying you know like for example
disaster numbers he's not nearly lifting
you know watch for your to go snaps my
turn 135 me telling ya with big numbers
yeah so 2565 for someone who don't even
lifting three years Bob see didn't start
to harm the lifting properly 125 so you
know I mean so he's got your seven years
on that so ever that person adds yeah no
it's not hey go what you wait at the
moment I'm 102 good up yeah since region
I just usually go it's got a diet know
what it is whatever I win means I when
we go out first time Nando's I said I'll
get this I thought that grief always my
house all the most expensive stuff you
just snapped up on it like waiting me
the food forgive them no no it's the
mini eggs
mini eggs every time we hang out no joke
if we say your baby John says to me
we're going to Leicester I make sure if
I don't I can forget half of my gym kit
but the one thing I will always take
this food proud
so I cannot eat with it what do you
think your calories are a typical day so
I kind of minimum I can't
yeah the minimum I can't system for most
striking mostly clean stuff in fact
we've got a question yeah how often do
you guys cheat on your diet how stricter
you guys how often do you guys on your
cheek we don't believe in I can cheat me
like it's nothing that's off of the limp
off limits that you can't have because
it just creates a negative relationship
do I have you coached some when you say
look you can't have chocolate ever again
at some points they're gonna have
chocolate they're gonna cave in I mean
think about this negative Luke when they
feel bad about it I'll ruin my diet and
just say good let's stick to my calories
eighty ten your foods come from real
good food twenty second time you get
enough someone that published stuff
because it's gonna stop you
binging on it or not and that's how sure
you don't get super lean like you would
have you would being a bodybuilder but
my clients and nitrogen people out there
aren't trying to step on stage so why
not take a longer approach which is
sustaining this and if you still have a
fun think this David or points exactly
strategize it as well one of the big
which means we do about biases educate
them about how to negotiate their
calories a lot of people tell mango well
I've got two thousand calories you say
I've got a happy five little Tupperware
boxers over the day Scott Lee even this
even a dime right if you're gonna go out
for a meal with your missus and you're
gonna go to the cinema you'd know that
that's gonna happen night unless you're
really spontaneous you're normally going
to know you finally evening yeah just
bring your calories back a little bit
throughout the day and this is coming
from Missy Yolo himself I'm not sure
you've got representative fitness sample
I'm just going to
nice macaroons over there a fancy of
Matthew I think also as well it's a
really important point to say that
especially with die again lean and more
mature from whatever is when it comes to
calories it's not done in one day a week
it's a month it's two months so we got
better to be consistently good than to
be awesome the time this [ __ ] rest I'm
an assistant easier to do and your
results might not be as fast but they'll
be there and they'll stay for good with
me I think a lot of people when they go
wrong I'm gonna wanna die they go so far
the opposite there that and it's truly
like a tiny little bit better maybe more
consistent and proved just slightly less
you know a slightly cleaner and just
make small changes and then it's
actually something that consistently
fits in the lifestyle we are you in sure
to be eat healthy but risen you use
three you know yourself we want to win
so we sell lots of mini bit tears I had
a client recently never do anything like
eight cans of coke live in a day and I
was like right that's way too much but a
new thing I don't know why you're
gaining weight I'm not gonna tell you
not a coke now because it's like going
cold turkey so I said what we do is
we'll cut down the amount something
until we get down to a couple of times a
week or whatever it wears a super per
person but the same with smoking right
it's very hard I think when it comes to
diet and create the curve gets you he's
done with habits and those habits don't
just go oh tomorrow I got a new habit
they take time and it's okay to not be
perfect all the time but in the long run
body of sex until you significant forget
that do you think going to atomic that
we haven't a chair today body building
which is kind of I guess I don't hear
the bodybuilding.com forums and like
that kind of this culture appears so now
the new things coming through it's a
functional fitness prospect weight
lifting stuff like that do you think
that inherently in the bodybuilding diet
mentality there is something a little
bit unhealthy and that with that
flip-flop between the super low super
high yeah a lot of people do but they
have a bad relation with fear
yeah that pregnancy show it's one of
those things as well it's like it's not
even just about the relationship with
food is the relationship with themselves
so we all we all remember when we were
our leanness yeah we've all got that one
photo that we've got saved on a phone
like I'm gonna kick backs it appears 10
times on your crappy on stage the strain
is how I feel you even get to that point
you know that's and they know it's not
sustainable but there may be a second
supercycle saying I didn't get on stage
and then they took it or they're not
good enough I have someone come to me
and ask me to coach them to give step on
stage and I said I wouldn't do it and I
said that each of their own but powerful
probably Jamie older than there's not
really anyone that I know who can step
on stage and then go back to having a
normal relationship with food and I said
I said to him was like what I see is
that I haven't walked that myself but
what I see time time again in people
diet make their life usually if you get
me stays and then for the rest of their
life they go they compare that they
under wondering about the cloud base
there and a some way to get back to this
kind of never seen them get back to that
again yeah why because you're stopping
yourself it's not sustainable
it's not a normal thing to do it's not
helping like mainly on the video while
back like everyone was had their
opinions on tests on it was the obese
woman in the front of Cosmo
yes holiday that's like that's extreme
let's eat rebuff we now so conditioned
to see people kind of steroid up to the
max in front of things and that also
doesn't help
but it's become normal to us so I think
we have the kind of question stuff more
than just we can't just judge a book by
its cover and that's what everything
social media is now is gog book by its
cover and that's why people are unhappy
I think that's definitely one of the
reasons why CrossFit is the uptake of
CrossFit can sometimes be a little bit
slower is that people don't like to do
stuff at this sucker yeah and the
barriers to entry of doing a sport why
there's so many very difficult like
perfect example you've spent your entire
career Sony doing two legs and you know
that what they're almost exactly to let
you think like you can go into a gym and
muster a supernate bicep curl in the
space of three minutes having never
lifted a weight before so the berries
went you could do it a sport like Oscar
are inherently a lot is but what's cool
about it is that you're going to have
something you're good at like keep going
sunny exactly super strong but there
could be an overhead squat anything that
old yet you don't you've never really
seen any documentaries or bio videos
done about codes material because
they're not sexy enough but you seem
like if you've never done CrossFit and
you see fits on earth you're gonna be
like oh yeah am I ever gonna do that
anymore
and it will put people off because
they're like well if I can't buck like
put up they don't understand progression
and it's that's the thing that I've
really enjoyed really come in and it's
not that level or nothing at all whereas
in the gym it's like for a bench press
or nothing - yes thing for me no because
I'm I'm never gonna be the biggest guy
when I was in a gym and I worked there
all I was judged on was how much I weigh
why quit I'm never gonna feel good I'm
never gonna win and I have negative
relationships a gym so I went the
gymnastics loved it then I found
CrossFit I read everything up in within
your box I don't even think it's just a
box you know so everywhere we go - yeah
we're welcome done but I have not been
to a box yeah where's somebody who are
not known and it's not known me
obviously right through the channel or
something like that
and that's not like I've never been to a
boxing along with everyone right yeah
everyone has a conversation at some
point if they even some of them might
have to see you do a lift or do
something then they go what do you do
when you do that where it's like every
every time you go into the gym if you
looked at it was just a massive engine
you know you have the forties gym and if
someone's doing something wrong you can
revise that bit offended I've never been
in a place like a CrossFit gym where you
can give someone advice and then go
unappreciated without yeah that being a
personal attack you know it's just I
think it's a much more holistic
environment for fitness and it's a lot
more about everyone to progress them
together as opposed to this kind of it's
you on your own versus everyone else
who's also on their own yeah exactly
much more of a team based I think as
well another great point is the fact
that you can drop in if you do CrossFit
oh I'm gonna guess that there must be
kind of similar with weightlifting in
here and that the methodologies the same
but I've been in Hawaii Bali Island over
the last three years and I've come
across weight in all of those okay like
the tree of three corners of the world
every single one of the places even if
you can't speak the language everyone
knows what you do yeah yeah they do like
balls of wool balls it's the same in
Hawaii
looks like it whatever so SUNY has got
to what are we going to do no I think
the Sun is just going to wait to wet the
baby's head right than you so guys thank
you very much I appreciate your time
good luck tomorrow by the concert I
think when this is out everyone will
know exactly how you've got on but yeah
thanks so much for having us really even
if you don't win you've definitely one
most Instagram followers I think I'm
wanting yeah happiest team baby will be
happiest if you open unders I think
means to me what that maybe the funniest
people to watch them carry with them you
try to get underneath me it's just it
turns into a piggyback does not get
stuck
[Music]
[Music]
you